there is a difference between a reality
a simulation and a simulacrum
the
reality that we are talking about is
something that fully emerges over a
causally closed lowest layer the idea of
physicalism is that we are in that layer
that basically our world emerges over
that every alternative to physicalism is
a simulation theory which basically says
that we are in some kind of simulation
universe and the real world needs to be
an apparent universe of that where the
actual causal structure is right
and when you look at the ocean and your
own mind you are looking at a simulation
that explains what you're going to see
next
and we are living in a simulation yes
but the simulation generated by our own
brains
yeah and this simulation is different
from the physical reality because the
causal structure that is being produced
what you are seeing is different from
the causal structure of physics but
consistent
hopefully if not then you are going to
end up in some kind of institution where
people will take care of you because
your behavior will be inconsistent right
your behavior needs to work in such a
way that it's interacting with a
accurately predictive model of reality
and if your brain is unable to make your
model of reality predictive
you will need help so what uh what do
you think about donald hoffman's
argument
that it doesn't have to be consistent
the dream world
to the the what he calls like the
interface
uh to the actual physical reality where
there could be evolution i think he
makes an evolutionary argument
which is like it could be an
evolutionary advantage to have the dream
world drift away from physical reality i
think that only works if you have tenure
as long as you are still interacting
with the ground tools your model needs
to be somewhat predictive
well
in some sense humans have achieved a
kind of tenure in the animal kingdom
at some point we became too big to fail
so we became postmodernist
it all makes sense the version of
reality that we like
oh man
okay
yeah but
basically you can do magic you can
change your assessment of reality but
eventually reality is going to come bite
you in the ass if it's not predictive
you